to the house ago and rest - and welcome
back to the walking dead DLC 400 days we
have wet Russell and Shellback so in
order for gender to be equal let's go
with the Russell Matt he's a beautiful
woman in a beautiful dress
I really miss the walking dead tone and
184 days and that the game has said it's
such a good atmosphere this game has I
really loved it
look at the map got like 60 miles left I
think [ __ ]
that's a lot that's a [ __ ] lot maybe
taken 20 cans what are you doing with a
can 63 miles to go
that's a [ __ ] load I don't trust that
so somewhere your brothers were
speculating that all the characters in
this game are gonna be the group that
Clementine meets in season 2 which would
be pretty interesting but I'm not sure
okay
okay no that guy's not getting up good
oh so he knows about Samus I'm thinking
that in the end all these characters
will meet and that will be the fort day
number 400 [ __ ] the wine I should
probably hurry I would get off the road
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what are you doing I must
stand my ground
that's right
I see anything weird I'm running
alright Prez you I read a lot of
comments saying that I should hide if
I'm Russell so I wanted to make sure
that I actually hide this time around
alright here we go let's hide ah I'm not
gonna say anything but uh you bros might
or might you reunited achievement yet
you might have seen it what I was
outside I miss calling with your
girlfriend down there ha ha ha
alright I just wanted to show that cuz
it's kind of cool at Easter Egg anyway
was that Kenny no I want to see I just
killed you here either stupidest [ __ ]
you think you're tough [ __ ] for both I
guess
I don't want any trouble no trouble
please standing out here like this ain't
gonna get you nothin but trouble
just leave me alone please I'm not hurt
no one
how do I know that maybe you're just
walking this highway looking for some
tale you're gonna end up hurting
somebody maybe killing you right now
there's our trouble country some good
but honestly I ain't no do-gooder I'm
gonna let you live okay three have some
balls on you just stand-in there like
that you get killed eventually ain't
none of my business I won't put other
name ass white don't matter what you
don't like the name Russell what maybe
that's just the name of the guy you or
your homies robbed huh oh I don't care
who you steal from if you did maybe
you're in a gang that likes to rob
people I don't know are you in a crew
you got some boys wearing hoodies I
gotta worry about leave me alone leave
you alone Russell Russell hey shut on
man no I'm not gonna come on you're
gonna get eaten out here otherwise and
I'm bored come on scoot
are you gonna wait forever what should
we do Rose huh see if I give a [ __ ] okay
yeah I'd like to ride that'd be good
okay well yeah get in let's tear it up
so many quick decisions and I'm like ah
I don't know up she likes to party
just get in we'll get there or somewhere
eventually I feel like he could have
killed us already
if he really wanted to have his gun or
whatever names late by the way thanks
for asking
ha ha ha ha thirsty don't drink and
drive it's illegal even for him to drink
but sure [ __ ] it
are you oh it good [ __ ] ain't it
hell of a kick but it takes the edge off
you'll get used to it actually I think
that's it for me I'm good alright
alright you want to tell me about where
you come from at least must have been
with a crew
any tailback where you come from maybe
drop you off do a double back I don't
trust him anymore now why is he driving
this Center or the [ __ ] Road can we
just drive can we just drive we you want
to sit on my lap I just don't want to
talk I want to sit on your lap you're
tough little nut Russ I know I know
oh my computer is starting to act up
it's getting hot what is going on he's
so awkward look man I'm sorry if I
freaked you out at first we all got our
way of coping with [ __ ] right I guess
that can come across a bit [ __ ] I
guess there you go
relax we're gonna have some fun don't
you tell me where you were before you
got here yeah I'm curious about this
there was seven of us I didn't have any
family Darren oh they're all my grandson
Statesboro there was a dad who had a
daughter about my age one guy said he
used to be a cop nobody really believed
that teacher his wife leader was this
guy Steve steel edge of the daughter
Steve was a bad dude but everybody was
with him you know he said seven was the
magic number we didn't add no eight
we found survivors it's the same every
time he he what
let it out Paco come on Paco that it out
we gonna kill these folks and take this
stuff or what then bang
they'd be dead anyway
how does man killing his bad Bros don't
kill people weeks of it I'll pack my
[ __ ] up I figured I could make four
grands alone and try to find my family I
slipped out of there I couldn't live
like that yeah I wouldn't do that [ __ ]
either yes cuz seven is a magic number
that's my daughter no they did da that's
all he did you give her strong six just
tell me something about her how was the
rat give me a little something just a
taste
Russ I'm doing you a service here I
gotta get my beak wet right why you
gotta be like that why you gotta be like
that that's what cool always talking
about women like that women look laughs
okay well let let me see if I can answer
your question always he's known in for
Gus lesson find me longer a man's got
for a woman it's all we got left now no
laws no jobs ain't nothing that make us
men but they ain't eaten all the women
yet whatever let's try this again all
right maybe someone who wasn't so near
whoa come on dealer wonder Finn what do
you think about the par-5 it's a 500
would you load that bullets in the glove
that guy is a [ __ ] area I'm really
curious how this one is gonna play out
now that I know better
with the first two how they kind of way
oh that's the gas station from the
beginning you bros pointed out in the
first episode you can see doc and Kenny
and it's kind of sad actually at the
Appalachian lies are here see if we can
fill up while we're at it
don't be mad I'm not mad fine be mad
just stop being a [ __ ] I don't want to
apologize
oh why do you always have to do that
game I don't shoot a gas station get the
[ __ ] down man you don't want to be there
get to the truck I'll cover you
how did I get out of the car you got
bullet huh sis dad don't think about it
just run I'll keep his [ __ ] head down
I guess we have no choice
Yolo good husbands what happened - I'll
cover you look out good you did
haha this guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I should have come down with you well
it's too [ __ ] late now it's too
relaxed Russell come on kid look at me
okay fine this is no big deal we got
this okay
no we [ __ ] don't first we're gonna
figure out exactly where this [ __ ] is
just get a quick glance you do it you
[ __ ] do it I'm not gonna risk my life
anymore for you no come on now
see easy now we know where he is me
[ __ ] how does he know that we know
yeah that's the spirit
let's push this truck for cover okay
it's in neutral just keep your head down
okay why is he shooting us anyway [ __ ]
just keep pushing I guess we can keep
pushing in a right [ __ ] push I am the
end of the road what now we're gonna get
around the side of the building we got
to go from cover to cover I can music
time I'm not [ __ ] around oh okay
you gonna cover me ain't gonna cover me
we get to that car we'll be out of the
line of fire here you can cover me first
I'm not [ __ ] around you cover me then
I'll cover you if you wanted to first
that's fine too
I'll cover you come gopher just shoot at
the window and keep that buggers head
down get where I'm going then throw me
the gun and I'll do the same
okay Dee you ready Russ cover my ass
oh shoot kid damn it Russ what's the
goddamn hold oh come on are you serious
all right Russia Tommy with my balls out
that's good good one kid this is your
moment
Russell big Russ let's get these [ __ ]
come on Russ we gotta move man
yeah I'm leaving you're right yeah oh
come on Russell cut the [ __ ]
look I need you right now right Russ
this ain't the time to [ __ ] around okay
yeah I wasn't as little before but you
know I was just trying to loosen you up
you're my boy right I'm not your boy on
your balls well maybe not right now not
no time look I like to [ __ ] around I do
okay
but we're in a [ __ ] pickle here I
know how much the [ __ ] Amman Azalea
ham well I'll work on that first
impression you got of me okay
I'm gonna give you this gun back now I'm
gonna shoot at this guy okay now let's
do this okay we're gonna do it remember
don't stop shooting fire
uh okay throw me the gun
and I'll cover you no I don't want to do
that
well I guess I gotta nice catch
go he's covering up go whoop I'm being
hot okay
we're dead it ha now we get over there
and we should be good
go I don't like this oh come on baby
come on baby come on baby come on baby
oh [ __ ] thanks.thanks
we're not done yet
I thought it hit us CP I thought for
sure you hit AK sneak up on business why
are they walking so casual follow me
this one is long this story's really
long what are we doing well we gotta get
in there
[ __ ] shot at us Russell relax man when
this is over we're gonna take what we
can head on down to your grams and have
a big whole home-cooked meal alright I
don't like this press I really don't
like this
come on okay it's clear
keep your head down and follow me you
got it
oh come on no way he did not hear we're
gonna be [ __ ] quiet we're gonna sneak
up on this son of a [ __ ] you could take
him out Jeremy okay I hear you [ __ ]
be let's go we should just take the gun
and leave honestly we don't I wouldn't
have any see him check through the
window see if there's anyone else okay
I guess that makes sense I don't like
this brothers this [ __ ] Popham I
think I saw a guy oh [ __ ]
grab him I'll cover you
why sneak up just jump out grab your
call oh I don't like making the calls
I don't like phone calls either uh-oh is
that guy [ __ ] deaf or some [ __ ] press
and hold the left Martin then push the
mouse forward slowly I don't know how
the [ __ ] I did that Oh get the [ __ ] out
of here you're monsters
whoa grams I told you not to come back
here think you can just leave your mask
at home and now you're with this [ __ ]
spook Oh
first off watch the [ __ ] racism this
is my boy secondly I don't [ __ ] know
you we were just passing by like anyone
oh [ __ ]
you came back to finish this off and
take all our food
lost you goddamn marbles she's dying and
now she can see your face shut up she
can see who took her from me mask what's
he talking about
[ __ ] it I know he's crazy have you been
here before Russell don't you start you
tried to kill us for no goddamn reason
if anything we should take you out for
that please just get the [ __ ] out of
here please leave us alone
I actually yes I don't trust it now
don't trust the capital oaks and take
all their stuff
we've been that road before we did oh
that [ __ ] face I'm done I'm done
that's it man I don't know you and I
don't want to can't you take a [ __ ]
joke
[ __ ] your jokes I'm sorry I'm out come
on can we still be friends no I don't
like this [ __ ] choice I can't no why
don't we say that a worthwhile liberal
they're gonna die anyway I don't look at
me like that
seriously uh it's a lot more intense now
that you understand how they like I said
in the beginning honestly I feel so
responsible and it feels like every time
I make a decision I make the wrong one
I hate that I hate it's a bittersweet
feeling I guess anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed watching this episode maybe like
if you did help me out a lot hit
subscribe to come over today and I will
see you and we're gonna do shell next
that's my boat